Aw,
Germany is the place where BMW Rammstein
and FK.
That's nudist culture were born.
Yeah.
Nevertheless,
Gemini has something even more important
than all of these things,
and that is the fact that it is the
world's ultimate factory.
Yep.
You heard that rice,
and I can guess what you're probably
thinking right now.
Wait a minute,
Simon isn't shiner the country?
You are a TV screens,
mobile phones as well.
Practically every good under the sun is
made.
Wow.
The thing is that's not entirely true.
Now of course China does lead the charge
when it comes to exports,
but do you know wasp,
in order to manufacture all of those
products,
they need to import a lot of things from
abroad.
Germany in standard sells way more than
what it binds.
In fact,
one out of every 10 product sold on the
international market is made in this
country,
which has a population 15 times.
It's smaller than sure
why now.
Yes,
we all know those big German car
companies like BMW,
Audi,
or Volkswagen.
But that is way more than that.
If you don't believe me,
well,
just consider your mobile phone.
And I know,
I know on the back is going to say
something like assembled in the People's
Republic of China,
but I'm not talking about this.
I'm talking about if you open up that
phone that you're going to find a bunch
of microchips insight as an example here
of that chip that makes your phone till
you know when you rotate it in the
screen matches up.
Vance probably most likely made by a
German company called Bosch Sensor
attack,
but not only that,
many of the robots is instilling these
Chinese factories assembling these
phones are probably made in Germany.
In other words,
in Germany,
they manufacture the things that go
inside of other things that are
manufactured by things that are made in
Germany and now you might be wondering
how is any of that possible?
I mean factories,
they should be built in places with
cheap labor costs,
right?
I mean,
how is it possible Germany with
relatively high salaries is such an
industrial powerhouse.
Well,
the good news is that today we're going
to answer that question for you,
but as always,
before we get into all of that,
let's take a look back at the history.
Okay?
Yeah.
Liberalism offset wells was it?
Europe was pretty done,
destroyed.
Countries like Italy,
France,
western Germany,
which was the capitalist side of
Germany.
They got a massive money groans from
their good friends.
Uncle Sam.
Wait just a minute because each of these
countries use that money in totally
different ways.
The French president for instance,
what's this guy that you'd see on tv?
Generally Joe's,
they go.
It all came from the military who was no
friend of private companies is political
creed.
The so called dirtied sma was
nationalizing big businesses and leading
the whole country's economy as if it
wasn't
army.
They chose a totally different path.
Both the Chancellor Conrad,
either an hour and his finance minister
Ludvig Ah,
heart spent years thinking about that
new and economic system.
It was a mixture between the composition
of free market capitalism and the safety
nets provided by the government.
They then decided to give this system
what is probably the worst name in the
world ever be called it auto liberalism
or social marketing.
Honami
addition is the most promising means to
achieve and secure prosperity nude vic
Elford and other words,
while the goal centralize the economy in
Paris.
Conrad,
I don't know.
I designed a system where the government
would put into place a set of conditions
that the other players would make that
own decisions.
This explains why in Germany,
trade unions,
regional governments,
and of course companies are quite too
important.
Didn't say.
Now you might be wondering what are the
keys that are needed for a system like
this to work and well,
has it really worked out?
It's all,
well,
let's get right into that stable
currency.
I'm pretty sure at some point you've had
some economists saying that devaluing
your currency boosts Zach Sports,
right?
For instance,
imagine we have a shoe manufacturing
facility in Mexico and we want to sell a
pair of shoes to the American market.
Let's say the price of the shoes is 2000
and Mexican pesos at the time and making
this video,
those 2000 pesos is equal to about 110
US dollars.
Let's say that all of a sudden,
Mexican central bank decides to print
money and therefore devalue its currency
from one day to the next.
The pair of shoes could be worth 90 US
dollars.
Therefore,
it'd be easier to sell these shoes
abroad.
Now,
this is a theory,
it's actually supported by most
governments today.
Now the Germans,
they actually decided to do the exact
opposites and for the later part of the
20th century,
the German mark was actually one of the
most stable currencies in the entire
world.
Wow.
This might lead you to one's out.
How is it possible that Germany could
export so much when their products,
what not actually that sheep.
All right.
Well,
let's go back to our shoes example for
just a moment,
but actually this is,
I'm going to tell you the story of a
real company.
This is a company from the north of
Germany and it's called Desmos.
It's not a particularly big business.
It has around 200 staff now,
this company,
it started right after the war being
founded in 1946 and they specialized in
making machines for shoe manufacturing.
Now in order to do this,
they needed to import lots of machines
from the United States and thanks to
having a stable currency,
the price for importing those machines,
it was relatively low.
They then decided to rent the facility
because at the end of the day,
since there was no inflation,
rents would not go up and they could
calculate the future cost.
All of this space reliable,
but
it wasn't any of that.
Since German companies could offer lower
prices,
desmond had to innovate and in 1960 they
invested in state of the art
technologies to manufacture rubber sole
shoes.
10 years later,
decimate was the world leader in pvc
souls.
It's in fact like lever at the soles of
the shoes you're wearing right now are
made by a decimal machine.
This company with 200 staff now sells to
every country in the world,
including,
yeah,
China.
I need know.
This is just one example of the
thousands of small and medium sized
companies.
The so called middle stand vertically
made up Germany,
the middle stand success as attracted,
admiring glances from the rest of
Europe.
But it's built on foundations that may
be hard to copy.
And yes,
I know,
I know Jim and mark is a thing of the
past because in 2008 the Germans,
they abandon this currency and they
adopted the euro.
But think about it,
while other countries like Spain,
they were using weaker countries before
Germany had had a strong currency for
decades.
That means that in 2002 German companies
were already more competitive than
anyone else's.
But again,
hold on a minute because there's many
other things that can explain the
success of the German model.
So let's dig into these now
the educational system.
Now I can probably guess what you're
gonna say.
Come on.
Zion in Germany isn't really famous for
its educational system,
is it?
And to some extent,
that's right.
If you look at the piece of revolt,
Germany isn't even ranking inside the
top 10 but then again,
German students managed to find a job
right after they finish their studies.
So we've not such a great educational
system world.
Why is this happening?
Well,
the answer of that actually the in that
boot Haitian or training system.
Now let's imagine you're a high school
students in Germany and you don't want
to go to university.
So instead you decide to study to become
made plummet.
Well,
from the first moment you're already
going to be working for a company which
has an arrangement with the school.
This means from Monday to Wednesday you
go to a classroom and from Thursday to
Friday you go to the company's workshops
[inaudible]
that you would be trained by the
experienced plumbers and you would get a
salary of between 300 to $500 a month.
And this salary is actually pretty
important because it means that the
company that a pain you really want to
make you work.
I mean,
otherwise the firms pretty much just
throwing money away.
Wait.
The outcome of this is that Jen and
students know how it is to be in a real
life working environments.
In fact,
many of them actually remain in the
company where they did their training is
of course these gen and funds.
In exchange,
they get well trained workers and
another on the subject of workers.
Let us move on to another key piece of
the German system.
German
trade unions in other countries like
France or Spain,
most of the labor laws are made by
parliaments,
but that's not the case in Germany until
2015 gentleman's didn't even have a
minimum.
Salaries were negotiated by trade unions
and employers in Germany.
Syndicates are extremely important.
Actually.
Those big companies like Audi or BMW
with more than 2000 workers are required
to have union representatives on their
administrative.
Instead of this,
Siemens has 10 shareholder
representatives on their board and
therefore they must have 10 people
representing the workers.
Remember that?
This one,
because it makes a big difference in
Spain,
there's an example of another country.
I think company like Telefonica has no
trade union representatives on their
board of administration.
The unions going to be participate in
another body,
which is called the company council and
they can only speak about matters that
affect salaries or working conditions.
Now by contrast in Germany,
trade unions have a voice on every
decision that the company makes.
When Siemens wants to start operating in
a new market or launch a new product,
they have to ask the shareholders of
course,
but they also have to ask for that trade
union representatives.
Now you might be wondering,
isn't this just bad news for the
company?
I mean,
we pretty much take it for granted that
unions and companies not exactly best
friends.
Well,
it doesn't actually have to be that way.
Think about it for a moment.
Thanks to this setup,
Siemens and bmws workers,
they know whether a company is doing
well or whether they're losing money,
and of course when things are going bad
for the company,
they can make compromises like reducing
their working hours instead of being
fired,
cut working hours at German facilities.
This explains why during the financial
crisis of 2008 German companies didn't
fire a large number of people.
Well,
this is good for the workers.
It's good for the company.
Wait a minute because I know what you're
thinking right now.
Please.
Jen and trade unions are collaborating
with big capitalists in order to exploit
the workers rice,
rice,
I mean it must be happening.
Well,
the answer is actually,
certainly not.
The reality is that the average wage in
Germany is around 3,400 US dollars a
month.
That's higher than the state of New York
and that's in a country with a pretty
affordable cost of living.
A flat in Berlin is about half the price
of a flat in New York City and despite
all of this,
Germany maintains its position as the
third biggest country when it comes to
export.
So then the question becomes,
do you think your country could benefit
from the German model or perhaps do you
think these policies are impossible to
implement elsewhere?
Please leave us your answers in the
comments section below.
Meanwhile,
if you do want to know about another
youtube channel,
it comes geopolitics.
You can check out the Caspian report.
It's a great channel.
We'll put a link in the description
below,
and of course,
do not forget to visit our friends at
the reconsider media podcasts,
or they provided the vocals on this
video that are not mine.
And remember that we published brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday.
So subscribed to this channel and you'll
never miss any boast.
Finally,
if you'd like this video,
give it a thumbs up and there's always,
I'll see you in the next one.
And if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice,
you can join us at reconsider media.
We have a podcast@reconsidermedia.com
slash podcast see you there.